[Music]
hello and welcome to
sophie ridge on sunday just when you
think
we're in the clear kovan 19 finds
another way to bring us back down to
earth
restrictions in england will be loosened
tomorrow but the next stage of the
roadmap
could be at risk because of the
so-called india variant
it's the latest cruel twist in a journey
that's had many of them
but the big difference now is vaccines
56 million
vaccine doses have now been given out in
the uk most of them
to the older people and more vulnerable
leading some to wonder whether we really
need to worry
about this variant well today we've got
the lineup to
answer some of those questions in just a
moment the health secretary matt hancock
will be joining us
sir mark walpole the former government
chief scientific advisor who sits on
stage will also be
on the show as will professor adam finn
a member of the joint committee on
vaccinations to answer
some of those crucial questions about
how jabs affect the variant
we'll also be joined by steve reed
labour's shadow communities
secretary first though we can go
straight to central london and talk to
the house secretary at matt hancock
on the programme today thank you very
much for being with us
health secretary um can you just give us
the latest figures
on how how widespread this india variant
is in the united kingdom
well in total we've seen just over 1300
cases of this
indian variant it is becoming the
dominant strain in some parts of the
country for instance in bolton
and in blackburn and
it's there in smaller numbers much lower
numbers
in other parts of the country one of the
advantages we now have compared to
compared to the past compared to
december when we saw the
the kent variant coming up is that we
have the vaccination program as you
mentioned but we also have this
incredible testing and surveillance
system so we can see these cases even
though the numbers are really
quite small at the moment which means
that we're able to
to take this cautious step forward
tomorrow
and continue on the road map whilst
monitoring this very very carefully and
taking specific
action in the areas where we can see uh
the the
the prevalence of this of this new
variant like bolton
talking about the surveillance system so
we can really monitor
how this new variant moves and so what
does the data
show us we're told we're told on friday
that it's likely to be more
transmissible
but the vaccines do seem to be working
against it is that still the case
yes so there is new very early data
out from oxford university and i would
say i would
stress that this is from the labs it's
not clinical data
and it is very early but it does give us
a degree of confidence that the vaccines
work
against this indium variant but it is
clearly more transmissible
and has been spreading uh fast in
in the groups where there's a um where
there's a cluster
and that means that we can stay on
course with our strategy
of using the vaccine to deal with this
pandemic
and of opening up carefully and
cautiously
but we do need to be really very
vigilant
to the spread of the disease and you
know the metaphor the prime minister
uses the right one we're in a race
between the vaccination program and the
virus
and this new variant has given the virus
some extra legs in that race
but the vaccine will still we have a
high degree of confidence that the
vaccine
will overcome and and so the main
message i've got for everybody this
morning
is get vaccinated if you're in one of
the eligible groups
come forward and get a jab in bolton
where we've seen a number of people
in hospital with this new indian variant
the vast majority of them have been
eligible for a jab but not taken the jab
so if you're eligible for the jab if
you're over the age of 38
please come forward because we know that
the jab protects you and we know that
with a high degree of confidence that
the jab will have
an effect against this new variant too
what i think i guess i'm struggling to
understand what some others might under
struggle to understand is
you say there's a high confidence that
the vaccines work
against the variant and i accept your
point that the vast majority of people
in the hot spots in hospital those who
are unvaccinated
but at the same time more than 56
million vaccine doses have been given
out
you know the vast majority of people
over the age of
50 people in the most vulnerable groups
have had at least one dose
why should we be talking about even june
being blown off course
um if we know that the vaccines work and
so many people have been vaccinated like
who is going to be in in the hospitals
well the answer is that because this
variant can spread
even faster than the than the kent
variant that we saw
and we saw what happened with that in
december it means that
if it gets out of hand we'll have a very
very large number of cases
and so even with the protection that the
vaccine gives you
that is the vaccine protection is very
high but it is not absolute you know 97
protection against dying from covert is
fantastic
but it isn't a hundred and so we do need
to make sure
that we don't get that total that
explosion in cases so we need to be
cautious
we need to be careful we need to be
vigilant and we've said at each step
we will look at the four tests that we
have we assessed those last week
for the tests for the move that we're
making as a country tomorrow
and our assessment was all for our met
the fourth of those four tests
is whether a new variant knocks us off
course and we will
will of course be assessing that over
the weeks to come and we'll make a final
decision
for the step four which is the biggest
step on the roadmap we'll make that
final decision
on the 14th of june um so
we always said we want this to be
cautious
we really want it to be irreversible you
know new variants are one of the biggest
risks
to this uh to this opening
because of the speed of transmission of
this one it can it can
you know it can really spread like
wildfire amongst the unvaccinated groups
hence we need to get as many people
vaccinated as possible
particularly in those who are most
vulnerable to ending up in hospital
listening to what you're saying there
you know the spread is clearly something
that we're
still very worried about and even though
the vaccines work
they may not work for everybody um
tomorrow it's because of the law of law
it's because of a law of large numbers
you know
even though the vaccine gives you that
huge amount of protection
um it it is if you get a very large
number of cases
some people are not interested
hospitalizations so some people who've
been vaccinated frankly
could still end up in hospital and could
still die
well a very small proportion that's true
under uh under the existing variants as
well you know it's the flip side of
saying 97
protection against death is that does
still leave that
three percent chance that's one of the
reasons why in over the long term
we talk about where we want to get to
with this disease as managing it like
flu
you know people get vaccinated for flu
every year as well
and um it's all about getting the risks
down to uh to a manageable level
and making sure that we don't see a big
increase
uh like we saw with the kent variant but
the difference between now and
december is both we've got the vaccine
which is great and protects
people from hospitalization but also we
have this amazing testing and
surveillance system so we can send in
the
the surge testing into places like
bolton and blackburn 35 000 people were
trying to reach over this weekend
even despite that sage are still very
worried
about this reopening that is happening
uh tomorrow indoor socialising
up to six people pubs restaurants homes
i mean exactly the kind of conditions of
course
that covid19 likes inside and just
looking at the latest minutes so
sage saying that if this variant is 40
to 50 more transmissible than the kent
variant that's what chris woody
suggested is very possible
then it's likely that tomorrow's changes
would lead to a substantial resurgence
of hospitalizations
similar to or larger than previous peaks
if that is the case why are we
proceeding with the reopening tomorrow
well the most important word in that
sentence and obviously i
i not only have seen those minutes but
i've also talked to the
scientists uh who are following uh this
with us and and advising on it the most
important
word in that sentence is if and we don't
know yet
the increase in transmissibility what we
do know is
that it's highly likely that it's very
possible that it is 50
and surely people would understand that
why don't we wait until we do know how
transmissible it is even if it's a
matter of couple weeks the thing is
though
the thing is though sophie and i know
that you get this it's often quite hard
to communicate
um epidemiology is all about the balance
of risks
and there are no absolutes as our just
our discussion just now about the
protection you get from the vaccine
uh demonstrates if the transmissibility
is as high as that then we will have a
problem
and we've been totally frank with people
and the prime minister i thought was
very very strong on friday when he
described
the risks that we face from this new
variant but
it may be that the transmissibility the
increase in transmissibility
is much lower and in that case there
will be almost no impact
on our on our road map and on the future
a number of cases
and we just don't yet know so that's why
it's appropriate to continue down
the road map but people need to be
cautious and careful
and we're anyway moving the the balance
more towards people taking personal
responsibility
and and trying to get away from some of
the
more intrusive rules that we've had to
have in place
and but of course we also are absolutely
clear that we'll do what it takes to
keep the public
safe as we learn more about this
about this particular variant and about
the virus overall
so you said that if transmissibility is
that high then there will be a problem
does that mean
that even though i know that the prime
minister has said that the changes
uh they want to be cautious but
irreversible
may you have to roll back on some of the
changes that are happening tomorrow
well i very much hope not and our goal
our our goal remains as i said at the
start
our goal remains our strategy remains to
take a
cautious and irreversible approach uh to
ensure that we're always looking at the
data or way
all the way through and crucially to use
the vaccine to get us out of this
pandemic
if you're looking at the data if you're
looking at the data
if you're following the data not the
dates it would be correct to assume that
the changes happening tomorrow
may have to be reversed if the data says
so
well that's that's not what i'm saying
i'm saying that actually the
the news and the data that we have the
information we have about the variant
uh thus far tells us actually that our
strategy remains on track it's just that
in this race between the vaccine
and the variant the variant has got a
has got some more legs i mean that's the
that is the
that makes it more challenging uh but it
but the
overall strategy of getting us out of
this by vaccinating
uh is on track and and it's only on
track and i just really want to stress
this for all of your viewers
it's only on track because of the very
very high uptake rates of the
of the vaccine and what's happening in
bolton right now
demonstrates why it's so important for
everybody
to get vaccinated when the call comes
because the people who are ending up
in hospital in bolton with this new
variant are largely people who are
eligible for the vaccine but haven't
taken the vaccine so if you're eligible
if you're 38 years old or older you
haven't yet had your jab
please come forward now because that is
what is going to help you but it's going
to help the whole country to get out of
this pandemic
the prime minister has said that there
could be serious disruption to
stage four of the roadmap that of course
the changes planned for
june when the end of this kind of social
restrictions was planned
how likely do you think that disruption
is i know it's difficult to say exactly
yeah it's it's the question everybody's
asking
and and the answer is it's too early to
tell what i can do is give you a
timeline
which is that we're going to monitor all
of this data
there's new data coming in every single
day
and then we're going to take and
announce a decision
on the 14th of june um as always through
this
pandemic we'll be as tran transparent as
we possibly can be with the data
you know you can follow it all on
coronavirus.gov uk
and we will obviously keep answering
questions about our best judgment about
that uh
decision uh and then we'll take it on
the uh
on the 14th of june so i i i'm really
sorry that i can't answer that question
it's because it's too early to say and
that demonstrates this
you know this uh this this dictum that
we have which is that we follow the data
not the dates
and uh uh we'd love to take that step
if it's safe to do so but
we will we'll keep monitoring and make
sure that we keep people safe
understood um would any changes happen
nationally or could we see a system
where
areas of the country with higher
incidences of
paces hospitalizations whichever measure
have
different restrictions to elsewhere
yeah well we don't rule that out um the
approach that we're taking in bolton and
in
blackburn is to absolutely pile in
testing
and vaccinations to try to get on top of
this
you know when we had an outbreak of the
south african variant
in south london last month
we put in a huge amount hundreds of
thousands of tests in surge
testing people came forward in their
droves
across southwark and lambeth and
wandsworth
and we got that under control that was
the testing tracing system working very
effectively
to clamp down on an outbreak now we're
taking the same approach
in bolton and in blackburn
we've put in a huge amount of testing
we've reinforced that with army
personnel as well
and we're expanding the the vaccination
program
especially for those second jabs which
are the best protection about
against ending up in hospital so at the
moment we're taking the
approach that worked in south london
which is this uh
massive surge testing um but of course
we don't rule out further action
and you know given though that bolton
has been in
some kind of a lockdown for a year uh
you know i i'm
uh it's not a step we'd want to take but
of course
of course we might have to take it and
we will if it's necessary to
uh to protect people now i want to talk
to you about
borders because there's a lot of people
who are looking at the situation
and thinking this could have been
prevented this could have been prevented
if the government had acted
more quickly so the indian variant first
detected in the uk
in the week ending the 29th of march on
the 2nd of april
it was announced that pakistan and
bangladesh were going on the red list
india wasn't even though there were much
higher
case numbers in india and it wasn't
added to the red list until the 19th of
april
didn't actually implemented being on the
red list until the 23rd
of april these this really matters
doesn't it
it was too slow
no i mean i've seen this argument be
made in some places and it's
frankly completely wrong and it
misrepresents how these
uh the the evidence on which you can
take these decisions
so you know this variant was notified as
a variant under investigation
uh after we'd already put india on the
red list
the decision to put india on the red
list was taken because of the high
positivity rate of people coming from
india and looking at the
epi curve in india when we put pakistan
on the
red list at the start of april that's
because the proportion of positive
people testing positive coming in from
pakistan was three times
higher the proportion coming from india
and and it was only after we put india
on the red list that this variant
became went under investigation and then
later it was earlier this month that it
became a variant of concern
about new variants should it the case
numbers
are also something that surely should be
looked at
if you just look at the data from the
16th of april for example there are 137
daily new cases in india per million
people in pakistan that number was 22 in
bangladesh it was 33.
and between late march and the 26th of
april
122 people arriving from mumbai and
delhi
had the indian variant they're just the
people that we know about
surely it was too slow
no so the first thing is we have some of
the strongest border measures
in the world and all of those people
went through a testing regime
all of those people needed to go through
a testing regime and a
an isolation regime but the second point
is that what matters is the positivity
of people coming to this country so you
can't actually just compare those
those test positivity figures as you did
because it depends on the proportion of
people being tested in those countries
however because of the surveillance
system we have here in the uk
because we test everybody who comes
through the border
we therefore do know where the risks are
and that's why we took the action we did
on pakistan
and then on india as i say before this
was a
a variant under investigation so yes it
is absolutely right that we have these
tough border measures and sometimes i
get attacked
for having these tough border measures
and i don't regret them
at all but you have to take decisions
based on the evidence that you have
you can't take decisions based on
evidence that you don't yet have
and we took the precautionary decision
to put india on the red list based on
the
uh based on the epidemic that we saw
there
and then afterwards uh this uh this this
variant
uh was put under investigation of course
you can't take decisions based on trade
deals that you don't yet have either uh
prime minister juice travel to india in
late april uh to try and secure
of course that all-important post-brexit
trade deal bit tricky if hindu was on
the red list
but i guess you're going to tell me that
had nothing to do with it at all
well we bet we take these decisions
based
on the evidence and we just had a
discussion of the epidemiology and
why we took the decisions when we did um
and the fact actually that we took the
decision before we knew
uh about this as a this variant as a
variant
even under investigation and let alone
it then being notified as a
as a variant of concern okay and
very quickly is it right that you're
opening up vaccinations to over 35
from tomorrow
um that is not quite right
but as you can see from the progress
that we've made
we are able to you know we are expanding
down through the age ranges pretty
rapidly you know i'm 42 and i was
vaccinated a couple of weeks ago it's
now open to 38 year olds and
and over okay a little bit more time for
me to wait then
hopefully not too much not not to be
selfish about these things obviously
um just finally everybody everybody
should be enthusiastic it's not
there's nothing wrong at all about being
enthusiastic about getting your jab
um i am also just of course the
restrictions
tomorrow some of them being lifted how
cautious should people be
are you going to be going around hugging
people yourself or are you going to be
trying to take a more cautious approach
from that than that
well i think we should all be careful we
all know the risks outside is safer than
inside so even though you can
from tomorrow meet up inside it's still
better to meet up outside
of course of course there's people who
have been yearning to have some physical
contact you should do that carefully
if you've had both jabs more than two
weeks ago that's much safer
so you know i was asked this on tuesday
and i said the thing i'm really looking
forward to is hugging my mum
she's had two jabs of course um actually
dad got quite upset about that i'm
really looking forward to hugging you as
well dad
and but you know we'll probably do it
outside and and
keep the ventilation going um hands
facing space we all have a personal
responsibility
we all know now uh the sorts of things
that are
riskier but we're just we just you know
we're able because the case numbers are
so low
to move away from some of the more um
restrictive interventions and
and anyway you know i think personal
responsibility is
is an important mantra here because
people have been so responsible through
the crisis and they've really listened
and followed the
uh the the guidance and the instructions
that the the
uh that the prime minister set out um
and
um and and that's the approach that we
should take together
but it you know it's really it's really
it's really good that we can take this
step
uh and just finally just one more
question to you squeeze in it's about
the prime minister's holiday because the
daily mail
reported uh this weekend that the
parliamentary commissioner for standards
found
he hasn't been transparent about that
2019 caribbean holiday
it was worth more than twice the 15 000
pounds he declared it to be
the bill hadn't been met by the
conservative donor david ross as the
prime minister claimed
whether it's you know luxury holidays or
expensive wallpaper
why doesn't the prime minister just buy
things that he can pay for and
afford well i think
frankly there's so many more important
things uh and i think that's what the
voters concluded at the
uh elections a couple of weeks ago which
is why we've spent which is right
actually you talked about one question
on this but it isn't important
yeah yeah and i'll tell you do you know
what i'll tell you i'll tell you what i
really think sophie
when we were campaigning in those local
elections i knocked on one door in
middlesbrough
and this guy opened the door and without
me saying anything
he said you tell boris i don't care
about wallpaper
i care about the fact you got me my jab
and that's the approach that i'm taking
so generally shouldn't ask politicians
about whether or not the prime
minister's broken rules
that doesn't matter you can ask me what
you like and now i'm going to talk to
you about
what i'm doing and covid and the prime
minister's followed the rules we all
know that
and what matters for this country is
getting through and out of this pandemic
and making sure that we can then have a
a great decade and the rest of the 2020s
it's brilliant it's been pretty
tough times i know there's endless
questions about this sort of thing
but i uh and i'm confident that the
rules
have been followed and what i do
is i concentrate on what's important for
the nation okay matt hancock thank you
very much for being on the program this
morning thank you
thank you health secretary matt hancock
uh there well let's stick to the theme
of kevin 19 and the indie variant uh
we're joined by the
former chief scientific advisor member
of sage at cemark walpole thank you very
much for being
with us how concerned are you
about the india variants well i i mean
there are
there's good reason to be concerned as
you've heard um
so there's a high degree of confidence
that this virus is more transmissible
and a realistic possibility that the
increased transmissibility over the
current so-called kent variant b117
is up to 50 more transmissible and
you've just had a discussion with the
health secretary
you know dissecting those different
points but i mean there are
clinic rounds for concern but there is
substantial
uncertainty and uh that's been the
challenge for policymakers throughout
the whole pandemic which is that they're
always having to make decisions in the
face of incomplete evidence
uh the job of the scientists is to
present that evidence as clearly as we
possibly can
and matt hancock said that if it is 50
more transmissible
then there'll be problems what would
those problems look like
well i mean the problem will be that the
infection will
uh take off and there'll be very large
numbers of infected people
uh particularly amongst those people
that haven't been vaccinated yet
people who are only partially protected
because they've had one vaccination
and again as you've heard uh in a small
percentage of cases the vaccination
for whatever reasons doesn't work um and
so
uh whilst it is perfectly true that the
vaccines and it's been a remarkable
story and we've got
you know two-thirds of the adult
population with one jab in their arm and
half of that number with two jabs
approximately
uh does protect you against um severe
infection and death
um nevertheless that isn't complete and
the challenge essentially is that a
small fraction of a very large number
uh that's the particular people who are
potentially infected gives you a lot of
people that could be quite sick
given that do you think it is the right
decision to go ahead with monday's
unlocking well that is the decision that
policy makers have to make it's uh it's
why it's easier to be the scientific
advisor than it is to be a politician
um the answer is that i think that you
are hearing them all saying well please
be cautious
um and the addition of fresh air to the
hands facing space i think is extremely
important that is the most important
thing of all at the moment
and the good thing about the time of
year the weather hasn't been great
is that it is possible to spend much
more time outside
and say and do things outside you should
and if you're doing things inside then
make sure the windows are open and it's
being properly ventilated
if fresh air is the most important thing
i i understand that it's a decision for
politicians it's difficult for
scientists for members of this age but
if fresh air is the most important thing
why are we going ahead with the
expansion
again you've been asking about hancock
that um
each of us will have our own opinions
but um i'm not elected you're not
elected so
um i i you know my job is to
help let people know what the science
actually says
um and uh it's job of course of patrick
valance and uh chris whittie to provide
that direct advice to
ministers and um you know perfectly
clear from the interview with uh
secretary just now that he's hearing the
evidence and he's having to make
quite tough decisions in the face of
uncertainty
but i think the critical thing at the
moment is to firstly that
vulnerable people who have not been
vaccinated really need to get vaccinated
and that's why it's important that
there's this
these efforts to serve the vaccination
to the people that are eligible
in places like uh bolton and blackburn
and other parts of the country
so that's really important because if
you haven't had a vaccine
it you really must have one actually
there's no good reasons for not
so that's the important thing um but
then it is i think a question of people
making judgments and you know my
personal judgment is that i will do
things
outside as far as possible um
so you're not going to be heading to
indoor pub tables then you're going to
be staying outside
outside for the moment yes um
you're talking about the evidence that
scientists are presenting to government
in which they can then make the
decisions
so what does the evidence suggest might
happen after monday's
changes are we likely to see a rise in
infections or hospitalizations
so the control of this infection still
depends on two things it depends on
social distancing because the virus
basically has to transmit by proximity
from one person to another essentially
um and the effect is the vaccine the
vaccine program is
amazing it's a tremendous logistic
achievement
and it has had a huge impact
but we now have a virus that is
even more able to transmit than its
predecessors
so uh it becomes a tougher race
um and so you know that is the that's
the critical issue at the moment
if you're looking at and look at the uh
stage minutes that were published
yesterday which were saying that there's
a realistic possibility that the
endovariant is 50
more transmissible than the ken variant
and if that's the case it's likely that
progressing with step three alone
which is the changes on monday would
lead to a substantial resurgence of
hospitalizations
similar to or larger than previous peaks
that's quite shocking it feels well i
mean it's a very clear
uh statement and uh you know there's
good evidence to back up the statement
um but it's why it's going to be
extremely important
to keep a very very close eye on the
numbers over the next few weeks and one
of the troubles with this
uh pandemic throughout is that there is
a gap
between someone becoming infected and
ending up in hospital
and then potentially the terrible
outcome of them dying or being severely
disabled by the disease and so you're
always paying catch up in terms of
looking at the numbers
now uh case numbers at the moment
nationally
are fortunately uh no there's about two
thousand cases picked up each day but we
do know for example in bolton the case
numbers are much higher
just over two hundred per hundred
percent of the population
um in bedford they're about hundreds so
um
we've really got to keep an eye on the
numbers so test
trace and isolate is really important
it's critical that people do get tested
and do
report if they have symptoms and isolate
themselves and their families
these are all really important things
but and we are going to learn over the
next two or three weeks what the
impact of the changes is and um
the problem is that the data takes some
while to emerge
um which is why there's you know every
grounds to be very cautious about the
ability to open up in in june but i mean
i think it's fair to say it is a
perilous moment
um we have a a variant that shows
you know good evidence of being more
transmissive and possibly significantly
more transmissible
we're going to have to watch the numbers
extremely closely
and the other thing that we do know is
that the this new variant
from india is actually quite widely
distributed across the country
so we know about the hot spots but it is
in all four nations
uh there's a fair amount about and it is
increasing in proportion
uh in terms of when the genomes of the
case is looked at
we also know that it's in at least 60
countries around the world it's in a
number of countries across europe it's
the united states
and it's doing what previous variants
have done which is that
as a fitter variant of the virus emerges
it takes over as the dominant strain
around the world
and if you like the relief with this
variant is that the evidence so far
suggests that the existing vaccines do
protect against
the most severe effects of the infection
and death
but we still have a certain amount to
learn we don't know how much
the vaccines protect against people
getting milder
infection and their ability to transmit
to others
and that's why this constant vigilance
is absolutely critical
you mentioned the june unlocking of
course matt hancock made it very clear
that that is
under review sure um do you feel that
normality has
got a little bit further away for us uh
well i
possibly uh but i think that people have
said all along that
you know this is a very uh pesky virus
it's very versatile in its ability to
you know change and evade that's what
viral evolution is all about and so
you know complete normality i think is
going to take a bit of time to return
and people have got to be sensibly
cautious i think
sensibly cautious what would your advice
be then for people from monday
well my advice is that uh you know
just because you can do something
doesn't necessarily mean you should as
far as possible
socialize outside maintain
uh social distancing you know if you're
good to hug
hug cautiously um how do you hug
cautiously
well you don't well without getting
great demonstrations
um tight glitches are should be avoided
cautious hugging i love it
um thank you so much for being on the
program and sharing some of your uh
expertise as i'm at walpole i'm always
good to
speak to you thank you
uh before we move on a reminder do check
out the safe ridge on sunday podcast we
record it straight after the show
it features the best bits of our
interviews plus some analysis from me
and the team and today we're going to be
going over everything we learned from
our guests about the indie variant of
course what it's going to mean for
the roadmap it'll be available from
lunchtime on the sky news app or
wherever
you usually get your podcast the last
one from me for a bit as well so
do check that one out now the question
that
many people of course are asking we've
been asking already in the show is
whether we need to
really worry about the india variant if
vaccines are still
effective against it we can sort of deep
dive into
vaccinations now and that variant and
discuss that with professor adam finn a
member of the joint committee on
vaccines which advises the government
thank you so much being on the program
so just let us know
how what the evidence shows on how well
vaccines are currently working against
the new variant and whether or not
there's any
discrepancy or some vaccines work better
than others
all right sophie yes so important to say
that
difficult to be very definite about this
particular variant
and the vaccines but we can say quite a
lot from what we know already
from all the different versions of the
virus and the different vaccines that
we've been studying through the year
and the one piece of reassuring news is
that
we've seen consistently good protection
against severe disease
with different vaccines and different
viruses so far
um and so i think we all are cautiously
optimistic
that that will continue to be the case
also with this uh
this version of the virus excuse me
what we're left with about is how well
uh the vaccines will be able to
impact on milder disease and in
particular impact on transmission of the
infection in the population
so that remains to be found out but i
think people should feel
reasonably confident that if they're
fully vaccinated their risks of serious
illness
will be much reduced uh also against
this version of the virus
uh if the the uncertainty is around
transmission or mild
disease does that really matter i guess
it would be my question if it doesn't
necessarily then lead to
hospitalizations or death should we be a
bit more relaxed about whether or not
the disease can keep spreading
yes it does matter because it's through
transmission in the population
that the virus finds the people who are
still vulnerable
uh there are older people and vulnerable
people who have not been immunized
there are amongst them as as some so
mark walpole was just saying
individuals in whom the vaccination has
been given but it hasn't produced good
protection
and the more the virus is moving around
in the population
the more chances it has to find those
people and
with them ending up in hospital or very
seriously ill
so transmission really does matter um
and as we move down through the
population
that is increasingly the aim of the
vaccine program to try and
achieve population immunity uh and and
prevent
uh and provide that indirect protection
and and
prevent hospitalizations that way as
well given
impacting transmissibility is so
important like affecting the spread
of the virus and do you think it would
be a good idea to really prioritize
vaccines
in the areas where we've seen hot spots
with the india variant
yeah we had a lot of discussion about
this last week and i think the real
concern is that because
vaccine supply at the moment is the rate
limiting step
if you start moving vaccine around from
one place to another or from one group
to another
what you end up doing is is disrupting
the overall protection of the population
that you need two or three weeks down
the line when the vaccines have had a
chance to work
and you end up chasing the virus around
and always arriving too late
vaccines are a really useful tool to
prevent
waves of infection but they're not
terribly good
at preventing them once they're in full
swing
if you like so our conclusion was that
we would probably do more harm than good
if we started making the program more
complicated
more difficult to deliver and basically
slow things down elsewhere
another big decision that the jcbi has
taken is about this dosing
advice and this change to the
recommendation that the 12-week gap
for the over 50s should be cut to eight
weeks
we've been told though haven't we that
the optimum gap
is 12 weeks that you get better immunity
if you leave it that little bit longer
was that a difficult decision to make
was it was a was it unanimous on the
jcvi and what's the thinking behind it
uh it's certainly a difficult decision
to make because as you've correctly
implied
it you know you're there's a gain side
and there's a lost side to this
um the the fact is that the reduction in
those interval
is relatively small in practice the
second doses were mostly being given
around 10 or 11 weeks
and now it'll be around eight or nine
weeks that will in fact
mean that the size of the booster
response that people get will be
marginally reduced
uh by having their dose earlier but they
will get it earlier
and there's a substantial additional
protection that you get from that second
dose
and we're now in a time of high risk
when people really need to have that
protection as
as quickly as possible so yes it's it's
a balancing act
uh but on on balance i think we all
agreed that this was something that
could be done
uh the folks in nhs england uh were able
to tell us that the logistics
could rise to this challenge and i think
it will do something to reduce the risks
of this anticipated third wave that
could follow
uh a dissemination of this variant the
size of the booster response will be
marginally reduced i mean
people will get a little bit less
protection from the vaccines what you're
saying
very marginally yes what's clear is that
spacing the dose out
gives you a bigger response when you do
get that second dose
but you have to take into account the
risk you're facing now
when you decide what to do and people we
really want people to be as well
protected as possible
in a month's time just in case this
variant is raging around the country and
causing real problems
so was the jcvr unanimous in the
decision
yeah i'm glad to say throughout the year
we've been meeting every week several
times
and we've always been able to achieve a
clear consensus we've never had
uh real uh conflict within the committee
it's a very functional committee
everyone listens to everyone else
uh and uh we've always been able to
reach joint decisions on matters of this
uh high importance yeah always good to
hear that definitely
and you're talking about uh supply being
the rate limiting
uh factor and just speeding up the
dosing
for the over the 50s put any of the
other roll out targets
at risk happily not
so what we're doing at the moment is
using our supplies of the astrozenica
vaccine
almost entirely for giving second doses
those are available the logistics in
terms of delivery
was feasible and because we've got such
an
amazingly efficient mechanism for making
appointments and people showing up so
promptly and reliably
uh we can do this uh without really
having any impact or negative impact on
any other aspect of the program
if it really is a race it does feel like
it's a race that's what matt hancock was
saying you'll talk about the importance
of getting vaccinations out as well as
quickly as possible
could the jcvi look again at this
recommendation that the under 40s should
be offered non-astrazeneca jabs if it
means that it could speed up that roll
out
yes absolutely that's that's on the
agenda
and if necessary that's something that
could be done when we
expressed a preference for
non-astrazeneca vaccines for this
age group it was done in a very
provisional way uh on the basis of
everything going absolutely right
and if the evidence shows that the risk
benefit balance
for people in their 30s is to be offered
that vaccine
then absolutely uh that that
recommendation will be changed
uh at the moment we don't think that's
necessary uh but
uh it could could well become a
recommendation in the future
that's interesting to hear and also
looking ahead to the future and
president biden
laid out plans last week to vaccinate 12
to 15 year olds quite soon
what's the latest on the policy on
vaccinating children in the united
kingdom
well we've just started having
discussions about this
clearly it's something that needs to be
thought about but i think the consensus
at the moment is that
children are very much not uh the
priority
uh very few children getting ill
very limited amounts of transmission
being shown to be occurring in schools
despite having
reopened um and and so the real focus at
the moment
remains with older people and people who
are vulnerable including children of
course
who are vulnerable um so that they get
immunized
and immunising children is something
very much for the future and not for the
present
okay thank you so much for coming on the
program it's always good to uh
speak to people yourselves about these
very complicated issues so thank you
thanks sophie cheers
well matt hancock was saying earlier
that tomorrow's easing of those
restrictions in
england is going to be going ahead but
of course the loosening plan for next
month could be
impacted by the india variant so let's
try and work out what labour's position
is we can ask the party shadow community
secretary steve reed who joins us
at now thank you very much for being
with us good morning
i've been talking a lot on the program
about the planned unlocking for
tomorrow hearing about the risks the the
balance of risks
and of course we'll be able to socialize
indoors with up to six people
should the changes tomorrow go ahead or
should they be delayed
well i've just been listening to the
scientists on your show there
sophie and they're they're they're they
they seem very clear don't they
that the easing the restrictions
tomorrow is the right thing to do
we needn't be um alarmed enough yet
to uh to reconsider that although the
question about what happens
in june remains now the problem for me
is why has uh the road out of the
lockdown become
so much more uncertain that it looks
just a few
weeks ago and the answer to that is the
prime minister
is not always following the science
in the way that he ought to be doing it
was just a
couple of a few weeks ago i was on your
show and we were discussing
the prime minister's plans to visit
india to speak to the indian prime
minister narendra
modi and as a result of that pakistan
and bangladesh
had been put on the red list but india
had not
and it didn't go on the red list until
three or three weeks
after those other two countries although
the virus was running out of control
in the whole of the subcontinent now
during that
three-week period 20 000 passengers came
back from india
to the uk and the indian variant
appears to have got into the country
because of that if the government was
prioritizing the protection of the
borders we may not even have this
level of uncertainty now now we have to
deal with it now we're trying to
understand
whether this new variant is more
contagious or not
but frankly we shouldn't even be in this
position if the government was
protecting and securing the borders in
the way that they ought to do
um i understand the debates about
whether or not the government should
have acted sooner
to try and um tackle the india variant
on borders
but just want to go back to the question
about what happens tomorrow
because she was saying that the
scientists were quite clear
my sense is they're not totally clear on
whether
it should go ahead tomorrow uh mark
walpole talking about
um you know the risks matt hancock
saying there's going to be a problem
uh if actually um it is 50
more transmissible if the unlocking goes
ahead we've got this sage advice of
course
saying that um if the individual is up
to more
50 more transmissible then that actually
could lead
the unlocking tomorrow could actually
lead to a resurgence in cases and
hospitalizations that equals or even
exceeds the previous peaks
so is the science really clear i'm not
sure it is
well we we don't know the answer to some
of the questions you're posing there
sophie and the
um the the india variant seems to be
more prevalent in certain parts of the
country at the moment than
than elsewhere and this is always going
to be a balance
of risks isn't it the risk of keeping
the lock down longer and all of the
damage that that's doing to the economy
and lives and livelihoods
and the risks in the risks and opening
up now we're in a slightly riskier
situation than we should have been
because of missteps the government's
taken over protecting the borders but
i think right now the the judgment to
take is that we should go ahead with the
lockdown
easing of the lockdown tomorrow keep a
very close eye on what
developments are so that we can uh
review whether the planned
opening later in uh in june is the right
thing to do
but short term we need to make sure that
the measures are
in place to contain the variant or
the the virus in those areas where it
seems to be
gaining more of a foothold and that
means looking at contact tracing
and making that work far better than it
has previously people who have been
self-isolating at home we understand
only three and a hundred
have been contacted that's not
acceptable but that system has to work
far better
than that and the the other core issue
that i also heard your your previous
guests
uh refer to excuse me is a
payments if people are afraid they will
lose
income by self-isolating because they're
on low pay or insecure work
then we run the risk that they won't be
able to afford to do it and therefore
people will be moving around in society
and potentially transmitting
the virus we have to fix self-isolation
payments and we have to get contact
tracing
working far better than currently if
we're going to keep a grip on this
variant whether it's more contagious or
not
okay so labour's position that
tomorrow's unlocking should go ahead
the one in june should be kept under
review
if the data suggests that actually the
transmissibility is what
some of the scientists fear then should
we be prepared to reverse the changes
coming in tomorrow
we always have to be prepared to do that
don't we if the science
tells us that the situation is no longer
safe and we're heading towards
another more serious and prolonged
lockdown then we're in trouble now
the previous decisions that the
government
you know dodged really like the um the
uh
the circuit breaker that sage was
recommending to the government back in
september october last year because the
government didn't do that
we ended up with a much higher rate of
infection infections over christmas and
into the new year
uh and a rate of deaths that really
could have been avoided
had the government acted earlier none of
us want to be in that position again so
if the science is telling us
that this variant is more infectious
than than it may well be at the moment
and of course
that must always be kept under review
because that's the way that we prevent
our more severe uh and prolonged
lockdown later in the year
should we be prepared to impose
restrictions regionally or locally in
hot spot areas or should we always be
looking
for national uh a national picture
well i mean my view is the the regional
tiers didn't really work very well last
time they very quickly
broke down because people move around i
think it you know the lesson from that
for me is it's best if we move together
uh if we move together as one country
but there are things the government
should be doing in the meantime and i
think particularly what i was saying
about
contact tracing self-isolation payments
those are there if you talk to local
leaders regional mayors
council leaders public health directors
they tell you
that these are the things the government
needs to focus on they have not been
working well enough up until now
it's urgent that the government fixes
them if you're going to contain the
virus without running the risk of a
longer more prolonged lockdown how are
you going to act tomorrow
uh mark walpole told me that we should
be hugging cautiously matt hancock said
he's going to be hugging people outside
what's your what's your policy
i mean we need people to behave with you
know as
much uh restraint as that as they can
i'd be going into parliament tomorrow so
i suspect i won't be hugging very many
people at all but you know i think we
can trust
the good the good judgment of uh of
people we know this variant is out there
we know this is this thing isn't
uh isn't over yet the british people
have behaved with extraordinary
uh self-restraint over over recent
months all of us are desperate to get
out there and get back to our lives as
as they used to be but we have a little
further to go until
that point unfortunately sorry to hear
that if you're kind of being cautious of
your hugging there's not many
parliamentarians that are going to make
the cut there
now i want to talk a little bit about
labor
uh it's been a difficult few weeks for
the labor party i'm sure you'll
admit a lot of criticism that people
just don't know what labour under
kirsten stands for
and it feels as if the you know the
conservative party messaging is kind of
drilled into all of our brains
get brexit done leveling up
um you know building that better
and if i'm being honest i was trying to
remember what labour's slogan was going
into those elections
and i actually couldn't remember it what
was it
secure the economy and protect the nhs
was the the core of the messaging that
we
were going into those elections with but
you know the point you make is um
is right uh ever since the the election
earthquake for us
of december 2019 labour's clearly had
an electoral mountain to climb no one's
made any bones about that i haven't uh
secured stalmer certainly
hasn't uh and in between here being
elected just over a year ago in the
elections we just had
we've had the lockdown so um as leader
of the labour party kier has still not
been able to get out there and shake a
real voter's
hand or give a speech in front of a live
audience
and with the country necessarily and
understandably
focused on the crisis and how we get get
out of it
it's been very difficult to find the
space to start talking about a forward
offer
from the labour party i mean despite all
of that despite the
the huge disappointment of the hartley
poor result if you look at the results
across the whole country they were much
more
mixed than they looked the morning after
heart people we were picking up
um council seats in uh in sussex in
hertfordshire we won 11 of the 13
uh mayoral elections across it was good
it was mixed i'm not going to pretend it
was good i
absolutely admit we've got we've got
we've got a mountain to climb but it was
a bit more mixed and
you know if we have a mountain to climb
which is how we've described it
uh since the general election in 2019
then
last week we had halved the tory lead
compared
to the general election that's progress
but it's not enough because we need to
overhaul
the conservatives if we're going to win
the next general election that was never
going to be done in one year no one ever
pretended it could be done
uh in a single year and particularly
given the circumstances of the pandemic
it's been very difficult for a party to
come out um
and project uh a set of proposals for
the future
as we come out of the lockdown as
politics starts to normalize and we face
uh face the future again without the
domination of the pandemic uh in all of
our minds
that is when labour can start to make
its future offer to the country
and the shadow chancellor uh the newly
appointed shadow
chancellor rachel reeves has already
started doing that this week
talking about work talking about the the
family
talking about the importance of place
and community to people we will start to
flesh out a series of proposals around
that
um and we'll do it by talking to
reconnecting with
and listening to the country so that the
labour party's
uh priorities reflect the concerns of
priorities of the british people perhaps
in a way that they haven't done in
recent years
she's got to be careful talk about work
that's angela rain is brief isn't it
the agenda that we will be developing
will be for the whole
of the labour party to talk about
together
and angela's a close friend of mine
she's a fantastic communicator she's got
a big role to play in all of this of
course
okay i take your point about the
difficulties projecting
your offer during a pandemic but the
issue that people have is
have you actually got an offer to
project you know
secure our economy protect our nhs the
conservatives could say
exactly that thing it feels that people
don't actually know what the big vision
is when you're close to kids start well
what is it what is the big vision the
revolution that many people want
i i genuinely don't think it's right for
me to just sit here
and describe describes you what the
outcome of a process of engagement with
the british people over the next few
months is going to be
if it's a genuine engagement then we
have to be out there and listening but
if we're just
doing that for 18 months you've been
doing that for 18 months you haven't
just suddenly
kissed time hasn't just suddenly come
into power some people would say that
what i'm asking you for i'm giving you a
platform
to speak to our viewers to speak to
people of the uk about what the big
vision is and you've actually ducked it
isn't that exactly the issue let's take
work
let's take work let's take work as one
uh
as one as one issue we know that one of
the problems
is that there have not been enough good
new secure jobs
in every single part of the country so
that every
place every town every city every county
can be the best place to grow up the
best place to grow old and the best
place to live and to work that
investment hasn't
been coming in so we've seen the good
old manufacturing jobs
replaced by low paid insecure jobs in
the gig economy and that isn't what
people need to see
now we have to work out how we are going
to work with the different regions to
bring in the investment
to sustain the good jobs of the future
that can give everybody the security
they need that their work that they can
get a job in their locality that is
going to see them and their families
through the future now one of the key
ways of doing that is through devolution
it's through opening up power so all the
decisions aren't taken
uh in in in whitehall but many more
decisions taken
in localities by people who understand
how their localities work better
now the government has been trailing for
the last two years
a devolution bill that would set out
their proposals for that
we got the queen's speech just um just
last week
no sign of the devolution bill they
dropped it and the reason i think
they've dropped it
is because labour won 11 of the 13 metro
mayoral
elections the conservatives are
frightened that when people see labor in
power they like it
so they've dropped their plans for the
evolution that is one of the key ways
that we get the investment in
and the infrastructure in to bring in
the good jobs of the future and the
conservatives are refusing to do it so
there's one area
where i think labour can start to hammer
them very very hard as we emerge from
the pandemic
okay thank you so much for being on the
programme steve read there talking about
covet 19 and also labour's journey from
opposition thank you
well that is it for this sunday and
actually for a little while from me as
well
we don't need to completely explain the
reason for that
um from next week you're going to be in
the very capable hands of
trevor phillips the writer and
broadcaster plus of course the show's
usual top stellar production team of
matt lavender
georgia roberts and toby scofford as
well
when i'm back let's hope that talk of
new restrictions new variants and of
course those dreaded
daily covered numbers are a thing of the
past and
i just want to say it's you know an
absolute privilege to be able to share
your sunday mornings with you
particularly
through the year that we've all just had
and i'm really looking forward to seeing
you again already
until then stay safe and take care up
next i'm going to be on your screens a
little while longer not getting rid of
me that easily
it's so if you reach the take where i'm
going to be going over what we've just
heard
with sam coats our deputy political
editor straight after
[Music]
[Music]
you